hey 42 here on the 12th of May 2017
thousands of hospital staff in the UK
from nurses to surgeons turned on their
computers to begin that day of work as
they usually do but on that day they
were not greeted with a login prompt but
this oops your files have been encrypted
their computer was completely locked
down unable to do anything except view
this sinister message it stated that all
their files have been encrypted and the
only way to decrypt that was to pay 300
US dollars worth of Bitcoin to some
anonymous entity over 40 National Health
Service facilities across Britain had
been infected with a virus later known
as wanna cry it ground the NHS to a halt
and many appointments and crucial
surgeries had to be canceled the water
cry malware
also infected among others Russian banks
and government ministries Spanish oil
and telephone companies car makers and
France and private individuals worldwide
water cry was able to spread so quickly
because it's exploited a vulnerability
in Windows SMB communications protocol
specifically wanna cry contained a piece
of code or tool known as eternal blue
that was able to effortlessly exploit
this particular vulnerability a tonal
blue was developed by the NSA
most likely to spy on people eternal
blue was stolen and distributed by a
group known as the shadow brokers
luckily a security researcher in the UK
discovered that whoever had developed
this insidious ransom war had a Bertolli
included a kill switch the virus would
repeatedly ping a gibberish domain name
to see if it was registered but it
wasn't so out of pure curiosity he
registered not domain and all of a
sudden wanna cry stop spreading
worldwide it simply shut itself down
many of the details of wanna cry point
to the fact that whoever developed it
was actually somewhat of an amateur
stas they package it with a relatively
obvious kill switch and there was no
automatic system to decrypt to use his
data once the ransom had been paid it
had to be done manually it was actually
just riding off the back of the
masterfully powerful and considerably
more professionally written eternal blue
NSA hack the US UK and Australia pointed
the finger of blame at North Korea but
whoever did develop wanna cry it brought
to light a festering issue that has
always been at the heart of public
services a ticking time bomb that was
only waiting to go off and will no doubt
to go off again I am talking about the
insecurity of computer services that run
our public industries and nowhere is
that security more crucial than us a
hospital but as it turns out hospitals
and other healthcare services have some
of the worst computer security of any
public service what a cry proved that
and it's only a matter of time before
something similar to one a cry proves
that yet again the frustrating part of
this story is that the NHS who were the
worst affected by wanna cry of any
organisation in the world could have
safeguarded themselves against the
attack with a simple computer update
water cry could affect Windows XP and
Windows 7 there was security updates
already in place to protect against the
faulty SMB protocol for Windows 7 but
Windows XP very publicly stopped being
updated by Microsoft all the way back in
2014 three years before the attack but
guess what in 2017 when one a Christ
struck four point seven percent of
computers in the NHS were still running
Windows XP mostly because the amount of
medical software such as x-ray imaging
applications that only run on XP made it
prohibitively expensive for the NHS to
upgrade certain machines but this fatal
mistake
also left the doors wide open for
abilities and malware some of the
software used by the NHS and other
healthcare companies around the world
was developed by companies that are no
longer in business don't get me wrong
the NHS and offer Hospital Association's
around the world do invest a significant
amount into IT security but all this
research goes into protecting patient
data and privacy because that's the most
likely weakness that if overlooked could
get hospitals into huge hot water but
there's a lot more to network security
than just protecting data especially
when thousands of lives are on the line
every single day and I'm far from
exaggerating the risks to public health
that poor Hospital cybersecurity poses
in early 2019 an israeli researcher
published a paper that showed how it
would be possible for a hacker with only
moderate skills to adjust 3d brain scans
using deep learning the idea would be to
target a specific high profile
individual who is undergoing of routine
brain scan or lung scan and tamper with
the results to show the presence of a
brain of lung tumor when in fact there
is no cancer at all a rival state or
terrorist organization could use this
very technique to stop a political
candidate in their tracks tricking them
into undergoing debilitating career and
life ruining cancer treatments for no
reason whatsoever but of course it won't
just be high-profile individuals whose
lives could be ruined by hospital hacks
a report in 2018
a year after wanna cry revealed that
poor IT practices and security in
Britain's National Health Service cost
nine hundred patient lives per year and
that's a conservative estimate some of
these are due to simple computer errors
that for example may fail to spot drug
overdoses
so if poor day-to-day computer practices
are already causing deaths imagine what
would happen if wanna cry 2.0 or
whatever the next big virus is
rikes what a cry was far from us
insidious and damaging as a computer
virus can be but parts of it were fairly
basic and amateur the potential for a
rogue state to invade the IT systems of
hospitals is alarmingly high and not
just in the UK but in every country they
all have piss-poor security must have it
could be caused even physical damage to
machinery and potentially thousands of
patients could lose their lives due to
an IT failure if healthcare IT security
standards don't rapidly increase then
it's only a matter of time until it
happens but surely NHS IT security has
been entirely overhauled and tightened
up since wanna cry think again the same
report from 2018 assess the overall IT
security of 200 NHS trusts post wanna
cry every single one failed to meet the
required standards that's right all 200
hospitals fell short of decent levels of
computer security the professor of
computer science at Swansea University
Harold Finley said that the levels of IT
security across the entire NHS are so
shoddy that's quote there isn't a word
to describe how bad it is
unquote US hospitals mostly dodged wanna
cry infections due to a combination of
luck and better adherence to software
updates but they are by no means
invulnerable to malware and if anything
that hasn't yet been a large-scale
malware that has infected a significant
number of us-based hospitals which
actually may work against them in the
future
because it will be a greater shock when
it does come and hospitals will be less
prepared all over the world hospital
cybersecurity is terrible but why it has
a lot to do with the staff who work in
hospitals on a daily basis don't get me
wrong I'm not blaming the incredible
doctors nurses and auxilary support
staff for wanna cry
or similar breaches but the issue is
that they are rightly so more focused on
patient Kenna than what's going on
inside the wards computers and they
receive little to no cybersecurity
training so basic IT security practices
are rarely followed in fact because
management puts little emphasis on the
importance of computer security those
working on the wards often take
shortcuts and liberties with their
computers that severely weaken security
for instance a typical ultrasound
machine will require a password to use
it but when interviewed staff in most
hospitals reveals that they will simply
create one shared password that everyone
who might possibly want to use yatra
sound has access to and sometimes that
password may even be written down
somewhere close to the machine itself so
they can quickly treat patients without
remembering their unique password I'm
fairly certain that I don't need to
explain to you how disastrously insecure
that is also there's usually no measures
in place to stop ward staff from using
their personal devices and plugging them
into the USB ports of hospital computers
which means the potential entry points
for a virus to enter the hospital's
apparently private network are plentiful
all it would require is a skilled hacker
to implant malware on the smartphone or
even a USB stick of any hospital staff
from a nurse to a cleaner then simply
wait for the inevitable to happen which
is that device being interfaced with one
of the thousands of hospital computers
just like transmission of actual viruses
is greatly minimized through strict
hygiene protocols on hospital wards
similar and just as stringent procedures
need to be introduced for the digital
variety just compare the hospital
industry to another large scale public
industry that has some of the best IT
security banks and you'll quickly see
why hospital security pales in
comparison and is actually
embarrassingly
weak yet I would say that protecting
lives is far more important than money
forest arts there's what's referred to
as physical or on-site security here the
difference is most stock walk into any
high street bank what computer systems
could you physically torch a mess with
if you wanted to without pulling a gun
on the staff and forced them to lead you
into a back room 99% of the time your
only answer to this would be an ATM or
some shitty touchscreen help desk that's
it
each of these are highly specialized
machines and they have absolutely zero
network interaction with the critical
systems that run the bank and keep
people's money safe now compare this to
any hospital you went to a gigantic
building full of empty corridors and
empty rooms plenty of places to hide and
seek around many of the rooms have
computer terminals in them left
unattended it's usually not that
difficult to enter a quiet office where
a computer has been left logged in by a
nurse who needed to run off to attend to
a patient there have been examples of
skilled pen testers a planting malware
on such computer systems without a
single person asking them what they're
doing it's far easier to do this during
a night when fewer people are around but
that's just fine because hospitals run
24/7 and online security is not too
different either bank security is vastly
superior to your average hospital in
this realm the vast majority of the
systems are transfer customer data or
funds over the Internet are designed by
or at least managed in-house by that
bank this means that every loose end can
be tied up and it reduces the possible
vulnerabilities by reducing the amount
of third-party software needed this is
sometimes referred to as minimizing the
hackable
surface area of a system hospitals are
the polar opposites the majority of
software used by hospital computers are
developed by a multitude of other
companies in the private sector then
licensed to hospitals from
authentication systems to transfer
protocols used to send sensitive patient
records to offer services in the
healthcare system the hacker will
surface area of hospital networks is
many times larger there are thousands of
different hospital systems that talk to
one another within any nation's
healthcare infrastructure the issue is
that each such third-party software adds
another layer of complexity to the whole
system and when it comes to hacking
complex and cumbersome software is the
ideal target because it is just
statistically more likely to have books
and vulnerabilities than a more
lightweight and streamlined alternative
the number of potential cyber security
holes within healthcare is enormous ly
higher than in banking unfortunately it
looks like it's going to take a few more
wanna cry style global malware scares to
affect public services before
significant changes are made as to
current rate of improvement is nowhere
near where it should be
honestly I think the best solution would
be to take the responsibility of IT
security in organizations such as the
NHS away from Barbara from Sheffield and
put it into their hands of those a
thousand times more capable this can be
done by migrating existing in-house
systems to software as a service
providers such as Google cloud or Amazon
Web Services this way almost 100 percent
of the security software updates bug
fixes data protection
backups encryption decryption transfer
protocols databases and redundancy are
managed by tech giants such as Google or
Amazon on behalf of the NHS and let's be
real here
these Silicon Valley companies are able
to perform all these services at a
market-leading level that the NHS and
similar organizations all over the world
could never reach or even begin to fund
if they wanted to of course there will
be those who have huge objections to
sensitive patient data being stored on
Google or Amazon servers but there are
ways around that pretty much every
service you already use today
is stored on those servers from
Instagram to Netflix proper encryption
protocols can ensure that Google or
Amazon can store that data without ever
seeing what it is if such a solution
could save a few hundred lives or more
each year then I'm on board which leads
me nicely on to today's sponsor dust lee
who will store all of your passwords in
a super safe way without ever having to
access them or allowing anyone but you
to view them - Lane is a password
manager that creates strong and unique
passwords for all of your online
accounts and also fills them so you
never have to click forgot password ever
again and you don't have to sweat about
the extremely rare chance that the same
could be breached because - lanes safely
stores and decrypt your data on your
local device only using your master
password
this means that - Lane never has access
to your personal data and any hacker
would only see random noise - Lane also
also fills your credit card information
whilst online shopping so you can make
purchases without even having to fetch
your wallet it also has a VPN with
country select so you can access any
Content stay secure and protect your
privacy at the same time with dashlane
you'll be alerted if any of your
accounts or data are breached it also
has a dark web monitoring system that
will immediately let you know if your
personal information appears on the dark
web where it can be seen by hackers or
spammers even if the public services you
use everyday are insecure you can take
the steps to improve your personal
security and be safe in the knowledge
that your data and all of your accounts
are completely protected by simply using
dust lane for my experience - Lane is
the best
all bases covered security and
time-saving tool out there
and if you visit my unique promo link in
the description you can get a free
premium trial of dashlane for 30 days
plus if you enter 42 it checkout you
will get 10% of dust Lane premium thanks
for watching and thanks again to dash
lane for sponsoring this video don't
forget to check them out using the link
below